attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
ah pardon monsieur je cherche qui
gardent à le moulin rouge
non non non c'est pour les sacs ce shop
boys et pensent parfois je suis mais je
voulais privilégier le contact human o
le contact humain amoureuse est à paris
si monsieur faut oublier c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui vous dit vous on sait que
c'est un autre touriste 1 et bon courage
et bonne bande est je vous n'auriez pas
une pièce si j'en ai plein et vous êtes
le quatrième que je croise dans la rue
vous avez un talent particulier
peut-être chansons mimes poésie je sais
jouer anglais mais avec une seule balle
ah oui donc pas de talent il n'y a pas
de fautes d'orthographe sur le carton
vous n'avez même pas de chien non je
vais vous en donner une passe que vous
êtes sympathisant des sas et 1,2 euro
c'est un peu gros
ça ça je tourne depuis dix à vingt
centimes up
bonne journée merci grade à noël
tu as des minutes pour l'association un
sourire pour les koalas du paraguay non
j'ai pas le temps non c'est fou ça
personal temps mais vous dites deux
minutes ça dure une demi-heure donc
ouais moi y'a plein de mecs une demi
heure c'est dur de minutes comme quoi en
rire mondialisation ça tu likouala
attends je sais ce que ça tient la
mondialisation non mais c'est dans ce
texte ils ont fait apprendre par coeur
bon allez tu me donnes ça je te suis
dans toute la rue je voulais ce sont ces
années monsieur h avec tt un bon gamin
je fais de la monnaie je vais pas
laisser dieval pour les koala et pour
les [ __ ] c'est à gauche
[Musique]